we've been talking about it for a while
and time has finally come as Tropicana
is now Tropicana as ndot will now begin
taking down half of the Tropicana
flyover heading into the strip good
evening I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian
loft is the cutoff for the last car to
travel through the Tropicana exit 9 p.m
tonight about two hours ago our own
Madison Kimbrough live near the area
with the latest right now Madison how is
it looking
the cutoff happening
it took us some time to figure out how
to get down here but take a look as you
can see the Tropicana exit is now
officially closed we spoke to nearby
businesses about how they feel about
this project and if they think it will
impact their bottom line
I can't even imagine everyone trying to
go through Flamingo that's normally
coming from Tropicana so it's just it's
going to be it's it's gonna be hectic
Christopher connect owns back to the 80s
Cafe and more located in University
Square Off Maryland Parkway he fears
Tropicana is going to be nothing but
trouble for many of his out of town
customers a lot of our tourists are from
out of the out of the city so them
having to you know come to our location
having to find different routes in order
to find a location it's already a little
hard as it is just a final location just
off of Google Maps but now it's going to
just cause a little bit more trouble for
them to get here connect says in the
long run it will benefit our city but in
the short run it's going to be a real
headache you need help fighting but a
couple doors down at Leilani's attic
employees aren't worried about it
impacting their business most of my
customer base I don't think they would
be too affected by it Vegas is growing
it's going to get bigger and bigger I
don't think anyone sees it as getting
smaller over the next few years so them
expanding the highway think it's good I
think it's just going to be hard for
people currently southbound drivers on
I-15 are no longer able to exit onto
Tropicana in either direction then
starting January 22nd Tropicana over
I-15 will be closed for eight days the
whole project could last until 2025 and
cost over 300 million dollars
as for the best way to get around all of
this ndot recommends that you download
their app which will keep you up to date
with construction now as for you early
birds we will help you navigate through
all of this tomorrow morning on good day
that starts at 4 a.m bright and early
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now